ald
[Silence]
continuing in
our journey
through authored by the light and
esteemed scholar of Islam
sham and we had
completed last week discussing what the
prophet
sallam
would
do after he was done with prayer whether
leading Salah or what he advised others
do
ofar we mentioned that the general
premise is that in
prayer we are in fervent
Dua and after
prayer we are in fervent remembrance of
Allah subhanahu wa taala based on the
statement of Allah subhanahu waala in
if you all complete your prayers then
remember
Allah
and now we are discussing and we are
going into the issue of the Prophet s.
wasam
praying
praying towards a sura what we
mentioned a barrier
and we discussed this
with u with quite a bit of detail in our
last in our previous
session and so there is no need to
review what we mentioned last week
however we will now basically basically
the way that we structure these lectures
or sessions if you will
is
that speaks about certain issues certain
topics when we reach each topic I begin
with giving an introduction to that
topic so that the person The Listener
has some kind
of Foundation as to what is talking
about a general framework of that
particular topic whether it's
forgetfulness in prayer or whether it is
wo or whether is whatever it is and then
we discuss verbatim What It
Is has to say on that
issue with regards to details and
then if there's any
additional things that need to be
said or need to be mentioned or brought
to the
table then we try to fill those
gaps in as well before we move on and
this has been pretty much the way
that we have gone through the book thus
far so last week our last session we did
that introduction to the issue of a the
issue of praying towards a barrier and
now we will discuss what says with
regards to the prophet s. wasam and how
he would pray towards a barrier he says
he said and when the prophet sallallah
alai wasallam would pray towards
something such as a u such as a
wall he would be pretty close to the
wall that he's praying
towards and he would only be far away
enough that a sheep could pass between
himself and the barrier and the wall
that he is praying
towards this is of course referring to
how far he would be from the wall if he
were in
sujud so if he were in
sujud excuse me if he were in suud there
would be about a cubit a cubit in the
Arabic language is from here to the tip
of the finger right about a cubit
between his head his place of suud and
the wall if he is standing obviously it
would be more three
cubits and so some narration
in and elsewhere in the Sunnah you'll
find that some companions narrate that
he was just one cubit from the wall
others will narrate that he was three
cubits from the wall others will narrate
that he was just a
sheep's you know enough to where a
sheep could pass between himself and the
barrier right and all of these
companions are narrating the same thing
they're just narrating in a different
light in a different from a different
angle some are narrating when he was
standing others are narrating when he is
in suud
ETC he says well
and he would not be far away from
the barrier he would actually command
and advise the companions that they come
near to the
sura that they that when a person
prays he should be close to his barrier
that he is praying to now again
extremism in the Sunnah
right which is referred to
as is that some people will read these
kinds of narrations and then be very
very close to their Su so close that
when they wish to make or they have to
take a step or two back and this is
as mentions
in something that is prohibited and
there is no basis for it in the sun of
the prophet
sallam he
said and when the prophet sallallah alai
wasam would pray towards his barrier if
that barrier was anything other than
a wall such as a stick and in the ground
or a pole or a tree he would
slightly stand to the right or left of
it so he would not stand with this thing
directly in front of him he would take a
step to the right or a step to the
left and this is referring to a
narration which has been collected by
IM
Ahmed and it is a narration that is not
very strong
and sometimes he would take a
spear and he would stick it into the
ground if he is
traveling if he s. wasam is in the
desert
in the wild he s. wasam would not have
a tree or any kind of natural thing
to pray towards so he would stick this
in the ground and pray towards
it and this
this spear right or Lance would act
as his Sutra
and sometimes he would turn his riding
animal usually his camel he would turn
it and set it in front of him and then
he would pray and use the camel as his
sura and sometimes he would take the
saddle off of his camel and turn it
and pray towards its end its end meaning
it's a back rest on the back of the
saddle that they would usually put on
camels this is
called and he would pray towards
that and he commanded that a person in
in prayer that he or she pray towards a
barrier even if that barrier is only a
lone Arrow which is stuck into the
ground or a
stick and if he cannot find anything to
pray towards then he is to draw a line
in the sand
and if there is no place for a person to
have
a then it has been authentically
reported that he
said now the narration regarding drawing
a line in the sand as a this has also
been collected by iMed and it's a
narration that when truly
researched we find that it is an
irration that has weakness in
it
and the idea that a person would be in a
situation where there's absolutely
nothing to pray towards not even rocks
that they could pile or sand that they
could
pile or a garment that they could
stand up or a stick or anything it is
very very unlikely it's a very highly
unlikely
situation and in that
situation drawing a line is is not
necessarily it's not necessary but it
does
Mark where a person would be praying and
so because of this the
scholars have used this narration even
though it is a narration that has
weakness in it they use it to mention
that this is the if a person is in
such a situation where there is
absolutely nothing
to there is absolutely nothing to pray
towards then they can draw a line in the
sand however this narration is not
very very it's not very strong to be
ascribed to the prophet sallallahu alaih
was as his
words he says
he says and if a person happens to pray
and there is no sura between
himself and his place of prayer then
nothing will completely invalidate his
prayer except for a woman of
puberty pubescent age
or a donkey or a black dog if these
things walk across a person's path it
will invalidate his or her prayer
now some people again this is an
authentic narration it's found in sah
Muslim and some people argue with
this narration and say you know why is a
woman mentioned there next to
a donkey or a black dog these are
issues which are yet
right
and it doesn't mean that a woman
is
demeaned by this narration or
narrations it however it does mean
that if we don't understand
something and this is this is an issue
that I really wish
my brothers and especially my sisters
would
understand and practice and have
conviction of and I really wish as well
that
especially those of us who have
grown up in a culture if you want to
call it a culture or say a time and
place that is so absolutely abolutely
Stark contrast to
the days and life of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
his companions and more and more
becoming in stark contrast to any decent
human
life that we
not
that we
not exerc ize a kind of hermeneutics of
Suspicion with regards to the prophet
Sall alai
wasallam Allah subhah wa taala
mentions that he has sent down a book to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam of it is explicit and
completely clear and other aspects of it
are fake are
ambiguous and he says subhanahu waala
and this is the in the beginning
of he mentioned subhanahu
waala that the people of true
knowledge their motto or their Anthem is
or their Mantra
is we have believed in it all of it has
come come to us from Allah what do we
understand from this we understand that
we don't have to understand everything
of the Quran and Sunnah and that is not
a prerequisite for us to adhere and
respect and follow and submit
likewise it is beyond our grasp that
every single one of us every one of us
will understand every aspect of the
divine revelation of Allah subhanahu
waala yes the entirety of the revelation
of Allah to the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaih wasallam is clear in
its entirety to the entirety of the
at any given time as a whole yes that's
correct but individuals not every
individual knows everything about the
Quran and Sunnah as a matter of fact the
only one human being who knows
everything about the Quran and Sunnah in
the sense of what is intended and what
is to be derived from it what would
have bearing on our worship of Allah
is the prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasam as for everyone else we may know a
lot and we are ignorant of more and so
when we hear something we shouldn't jump
to the conclusion that I need an answer
to this right now I need to understand
what this means this second and if I
can't understand it in the way that I am
right now with the amount of information
that I have then it can't be true and I
will dismiss it this is very
dangerous okay there are things that a
person will learn and not understand
until way later in
life and there are things that a person
may understand and learn and be able to
put into words way later in life just
because a piece of information has come
to you doesn't mean that you are ready
to understand it yet and this is what
comes from the human being the Muslim
the believer understanding his or her
limitations and understanding that this
book is very complicated book Muslim is
a very complicated book the Quran is
unimaginably complex book right and and
people will spend their
lifetime and still not have scratched
the surface with regards to some of its
secrets and some of its and so for a
person to have this idea that this
doesn't sound right therefore I'm going
to dismiss it this is very dangerous
imagine with me for a sec for a
moment
that a person did this with a car with a
vehicle you have that that
same attitude with a vehicle what do
I mean well the average person who is
not a mechanic do we understand
everything about the vehicle no when we
open the hood and we see this engine
there do we understand everything about
it no we probably don't know most of
what goes on in there that doesn't
stop us from reaping the benefits of
this vehicle now now imagine if a person
got into a car they don't know anything
about the car however they start to
dismiss parts of that car simply because
they don't understand it or it doesn't
fit into what they thought reality was
so they open the hood and they see all
these wires say I don't know what that
is that that looks ridiculous I'm going
to remove that that I don't think and I
think this and I think that well they're
going to very quickly destroy the car
and the person who's going to suffer for
that is
themselves and
so we have to understand
that if you
read a verse of the Quran and do not
understand it if you read a Sunnah of
the Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam if
and do not understand it if you
read
a an opinion of a scholar or a ruling
or a feta that you do not understand and
it comes from a
respectable scholarly Source in Islam
in the Islamic World whether of past
ancient or contemporary times just
because you don't understand it just
because it sounds outlandish doesn't
mean that you have the right to dismiss
it because the Hallmark of the believer
is
you they believe in the Unseen they
believe in that which they have no means
of truly perceiving with their with
anything but their minds this is what is
meant
by excuse me and
so sometimes we'll see this a
scholar from the east or west will
give an answer to a question or pass a
feta and this scholar is qualified to
do so
and maybe a newscast or a news source
will pick it up and kind of make a
mockery of it and say this scholar says
this 1 two 3 4 five and look at this
ridiculous thing and how could they say
this and so on and so forth and it's
very easy to jump on this
bandwagon and to tweet this and
resend it right and this is very very
incorrect you do not want to get into
that murky
water right if you do not understand
something
say if you wish to research it research
it but recognize that unless you are a
scholar unless you are absolutely
proficient in most of the Sciences of
the Arabic language unless you are
proficient and can call to and can call
to mind the majority of of the Quran
the majority of the Sunnah of the
Prophet Sall alai wasam at any given
moment if you are not well acquainted
with how the scholars of Islam have
understood the Quran and Sunnah and
passed it down generation upon after
generation if you do not meet these
qualifications which few people do then
it's better for you to remain silent and
you'll learn a lot more if you are
silent
but this idea that we need to have an
answer for everything and if I can't
understand it it can't be understood
this is definitely derived from
arrogance and it is exactly what has
destroyed previous
Nations Allah subhanahu wa taala says
about the Nations who disbelieved in
their prophets and Messengers
he said they have belied and
rejected that which they have not
completely
understood and its explanation has not
come to
them he
says likewise have the previous
Nations dis
believed and look at how the outcome of
the oppressive are because that's that's
that's
transgression that is oppressive for a
person to dismiss something before
completely understanding
it
and when you are dealing with the Quran
and
Sunnah that is a red line when you are
dealing with the scholars of Islam we do
not holif Scholars we do not put them
Beyond fallibility yes they can make
mistakes yes they but they but the
nature of a scholar is that he is right
more than he is
wrong that he remembers more than he
forgets that he is in accordance with
the Quran and Sunnah more than he is not
Etc and so being that that is the case
you must deal with them ACC
accordingly when you make a mockery of
something or deny something or reject
something or bely something that has
come to
you from the scholars of Islam you very
well could be rejecting something that
has come from Allah subhah waala and
it's very likely
actually the prophet sallallah alai
wasam warned us of this of this
danger and he said sallallah alai
wasallam as is
in he
says do
not he said if the people of the book
the Christians the Jews if they tell you
of something that is in their
books then do not reject it and do not
accept it right do not reject it and do
not accept it now he's speaking about
that which is
unclear for example the Divinity of
Christ that is clear that is that is
something that Allah has clarified and
so we reject that out the gates right or
for example the prophethood of Moses for
instance this is something that Allah
has has affirmed in the Quran but what
he is speaking speaking about our
details things that we are not sure of
they could be correct and they could be
incorrect and so we do not accept them
and we do not reject them because they
could be of the truth that has come to
us from Allah has come to them from
Allah and if we reject it we will be
rejecting a portion of our own message
for that in for that
matter and if it is not from Allah we
may be accepting something that and
ascribing something to the truth that
is not of it this is with the people of
the book whom Allah subhah waala told us
in the Quran have altered their books
and have changed their books and have
twisted their tongues while they speak
in a way that would cause people to
be confused with regards to what has
come to them and what they know and the
the deviance of The Scholar of the
previous Nations so how much more
so the scholarship of the Muslim
world
and there is a kind of wave or a kind of
fad going around now on social
media that a scholar should look a
certain way in our new age you shouldn't
be able to distinguish a
scholar from
a non-muslim for that matter right they
don't have long beards if they're a
Woman They don't wear
n they look your average guy your
average college student right and
Scholars from East that have full beard
or that dress a particular way that
this has kind of been given to us as
this is an image of of primitiveness
and these people are unsophisticated
and they are living in two 300 years ago
and all this stuff this is very
dangerous and this all comes from the
infiltration and
the the the
the
intellectual
colonization that has come to the Muslim
world after it was left in tatters right
so it's important that you are aware
that you think for yourself question
these authorities you cannot allow
yourself to Simply jump on a bandwagon
or ride a wave because that wave may
be or that bandwagon may be on its
way to hell and you don't want to be on
that one and so it's important that back
to the original part when you read the
Quran and
Sunnah there's going to be a lot of
stuff that you don't understand a lot of
things that sound very outlandish a lot
of things that
sound but you are not going to moralize
or judge these things based on who you
are what you think things should
be rather you open your heart you open
your mind and you
say it is something that we believe in
all of it it has some it is something
that has come to us from our
Lord and if it is a command then your
Mantra
is we have heard and we obey that is it
and if I understand that is great and
that is lovely and that is wonderful and
we should seek out understanding however
if I fail to understand perhaps I never
will but I will not deprive myself of
that of that guidance that has come
to me and just imagine if you did this
in the real world right you go to the
doctor you don't understand the
diagnosis so you refuse to accept it and
you dismiss it you go to the pharmacist
and you refuse the medication because
you don't understand how it works or
you've never heard of that before right
imagine what your life would be like
this is something that you have to
get under control we understand as human
beings that Allah has divided us into
two categories leaders and those who are
LED not everybody can be a leader and
not everybody can be a follower you are
either a follower or a leader you choose
based on your best judgment and utmost
of sincerity who to follow and and
Allah subhanahu waala has placed those
leaders for us in order that we can be
led correctly
right he
says he says and any
narrations that nullify this ruling
meaning that person's prayer will be
nullified by these three things that may
cross in front of him and when we say
cross in front of him we don't mean from
here to the wall we're talking about if
you have no barrier then three cubits
ahead is the most that any of the
four imams have mentioned others mention
you and your place of suud so if
something passes beyond that it will not
affect your prayer what will fect your
prayer is within those three cubits or
from where you are standing to your
place of suud if one of those three
things passes in front of you there then
it will nullify your prayer when we say
the black dog we are speaking about a
dog that has no white in it anywhere no
other color at all it has to be
completely 100%
black
he says and any
narration that seems to contradict
this that these three things will
nullify a person's prayer they are
either that narration is either
authentic but
inexplicit not clear or it is explicit
but not authentic
he says and this is only for one who
passes passes passes in front of you not
for someone who is sitting in front of
you the prophet sallallah alai
wasam was narrated and this narration is
collected by IM Muslim was narrated to
have prayed
Anda is would be sleeping in front of
him and when he would go for sujud he
would touch her foot and she would move
her feet and he would make suud Etc
because of the tightness of the place he
says and a person being in front of you
sitting in front of you laying in front
of you is not the same as somebody
passing what invalidates a person's
prayer is someone
passing not a person sitting and it is
not impermissible for a person to be
sitting in front of someone who is
praying this is something that IB Abbas
would do as well if he is in the Masjid
and he is not anywhere near a pillar or
wall where he could use as a Sutra he
would have one of his students or one
of his companions one of his friends
turn around and he would pray towards
his back so if I come into the Masid and
I stand there and there's someone
sitting in front of me with their back
towards me I can pray and use them as my
Sutra this is what the companions
were narrated to have done as
well he
says now we are going to move on
to what the prophet Sall wasam would
pray what the prophet s. wasallam
would
pray outside of the five prayers so
now we're going to get into the
what he would pray after the five
prayers then we will get into inshallah
his traditions in making the night
prayer
or then we will get
into
these will be next week
inshallah and then we'll get into issues
of the day of and how he would
observe J he and his
companions he says
[Silence]
he
says and the prophet sallallah alai
wasam would consistently pray 10 prayers
along with his five daily
prayers all of the
time when he was a resident meaning as
long as he was not
traveling and these 10
prayers are as ibar
narrates I have learned from the
messenger of Allah s. wasam 10
units of prayer to be prayed along
with the five daily prayers he said
two units two ra
before and two
after and two two units
after and two after and usually he would
do this in his house in his home he
would not do it in the Masjid sallallahu
alaih wasallam
and two as well before the two of fud so
we have 10 in all so we have two before
two before two after two after two
after and once it had occurred that the
prophet s.
wasam was tending to to some
matter and was unable to pray the two
before and so he prayed them those two
ra he made them up
after and this in this is an evidence
that a person can make up those lost
things that he would do that are not
obligations so let's say a person
usually fasts Mondays and Thursdays they
miss one day they can make it up any
other day of the week to make up
something that is a something that is
must something that is not binding is
not obligatory this is part of the
Sunnah of the Prophet Sall alai wasam
and the companions were narrated to have
done so as well what he
says he said and sometimes he would pray
before four as opposed to two this is
sometimes but the bare minimum was two
and sometimes
four he says and as for two
before it has been authentically
collected and reported that he said to
the companions advising them pray
before pray before pray
before he said three times and then he
said whoever wishes to so it is
something that is advisable but it is
not
binding and he said for whoever desires
to out of fear that people would turn it
into something that would be constantly
done all the time never never left
off and this is something that he
himself did not
do and this is the correct opinion says
that two before is something that is
advisable encouraged yet it is not
something that was a consistent Sunnah
of the Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
that he would do without
fail he says and he would pray most of
the most of the optional prayers and
additional prayers and prayers that have
no particular
cause for example making W that is
a cause a cause for that two that you
made W or for example a cause like
entering the Masid you make two ra
before you sit down he says most of
these sun he would pray them as long as
they are not a Sunnah that has a cause
to it we've just mentioned he would
usually pray them in his home except
for he would usually make in the Masjid
sallallah alaihi
wasallam except
for he would make most of these in his
home except
especially he would most always make in
his
home it has never been narrated that the
prophet Sall
made in in the Masid ever that it was
always something that he did in his
homeid he says and it is permissible for
a person to make it in the Masjid if he
chooses but this is how it was narrated
from the prophet sallam
and the most practiced Sunnah that
the prophet
Sall would make would be the two
before more than all of the
other that he would
make and so he would never fail to
make two before and as well never fail
to make the one bare minimum one
of this is something that we will
speak about later inshallah but he would
never fail to make these whether he was
resident at the time or he was traveling
even in travel he would always make
these
two he
says he says
and it has never been narrated that the
prophet s. wasam prayed
the you know two before two after two
after two after that he would ever have
made these while
traveling either them or anything
else only these two that he would always
practice which is and
these are the only two the others he
would never make while traveling and as
a matter of fact many of the
companions of them abdah as is in
Muslim would
actually tell people that he would
see in travel
praying in addition to their obligatory
Salah not to do that and he was
say and he would say if I am if I was
going to pray the I would have just
prayed the full prayer because when a
person is traveling he's no longer
making four for he's now making two he's
making two for he's making excuse me and
he's making two
for so what is the point of shortening
that prayer only to pray the
as you normally would this defeats the
purpose
of
so would say if I was going to pray the
then I would have started by making
the full Salah or the full excuse me the
full obligatory Salah
first right so you're kind of defeating
the purpose you're you're making
you're you're shortening something that
is obligatory and then you are
maintaining something that is a Sunnah
and it should be the opposite
right he says
[Silence]
says the jurists of Islam have
differed with regards to what is
more what is
more
important and what is more should
be more strongly and stringently
practiced which is more virtuous
the two of before F that Sunnah or the
one of after he says this is a
difference of opinion amongst the
scholars of Islam he says and the two
before
Sunnah these two ra kind of represent
the beginning of a person's actions
meaning for that day and the
wi the last
last of the night after is this is
symbolic of the end of his deeds at the
end of his day at the end of his life
[Silence]
he says and because of this symbolism
found in these two in these two Sun so
the two before they are symbolic of the
beginning of a person's actions and
deeds of that day of his life
and the last and final Witter one of wi
this is symbolic of a person's the
the the end of his deeds right and what
he what he ends his deeds with right
because of this symbolism found in these
two the prophet Sall alai wasam would
end begin and end his day in these Sun
by reciting the two Surah the two
chapters
of the two chapters
of what are
he said they are the two chapters of the
Quran that contain in them the
monotheism of both knowledge and action
the monotheism of knowledge and
Direction and The monotheism of
belief the monotheism of
intent and he is referring
to and
these are the two chapters he's actually
referring to
[Silence]
here he
says the chapter of
this chapter contains and entails what
is
obligatory with regards to affirming
and belief with regards to Allah with
regards to his
Oneness which in itself negates any
Partners in any way that would be
ascribed unto he subh
likewise this
chapter it also entails and contains in
it a
declaration of negating any child or
offspring be ascribed to Allah or that
he is The Offspring or result or the
effect of some other cause subhanahu wa
taala with which
would by which would in turn affirm
Allah
subh total and meaning Allah subhana
says Allah what is meant by a has seven
main meanings amongst the companions
one of which is the one whom all the
creation
intend and turn to and he subhah waala
turns to none the one whom everything is
is in need of and must turn to for their
existence yet he subhah
waala is independent and needs not turn
to anyone or anything for his own
existence
likewise this
chapter Allah subhana says in the final
verse of
it he
says in the final verse and there is
nothing unto he nothing similar
nothing equal
to him subhanahu waala and so this
chapter concludes by
negating any existence of a similar or
an equal to himself subhanahu wa taala
and this all entails that there is
nothing him there is nothing
similar to him there is nothing equal to
him subhah waa
so this
chapter it articulates and affirms for
Allah either directly or entails
affirming every Perfection to Allah
negating any
imperfection from Allah subh
[Silence]
with
Quran
[Silence]
for e
so this chapter here essentially is
discussing the two types ofed and really
we don't want to just translate it right
through because it is owed a lot more
attention than we can give it in the
final few minutes here and so we will
keep this for next week
inshallah suffice to us to understand
that throughout the Quran and Sunnah
monotheism of Allah is two main parts
two main types there
is there
is monotheism of of knowledge which
means some Scholars refer to it
as different names that are given to
these two types of yet when we look into
the Quran andah we see the types of
monotheism in the Quran that are
mentioned can see that they are mainly
they are mainly split into two types you
have toed monotheism which is
essentially knowledge about Allah his
names his attributes his actions
Etc and the second type ofed which
is which is that a person be pure and
monotheist in his intention that he
worship Allah alone without any Partners
these are the two types of toed the two
main types of
and so we find
that is symbolic and contains all of the
fundamentals and principles
of
and contains all of the pr
fundamentals of
and so because of this he would start
his day and he would end his day with
these two right and we will get into
that more deeply next week inshallah we
will now hear the and make